I hate that I have to do this video but
after more than two weeks I don't have a
choice anymore because our YouTube
channel is quite frankly on the verge of
death here's the story
on January 9th mysteriously there was a
roughly six to seven hour period during
which our live analytics showed almost
no views the next day things were
supposedly fixed after three or four
days some slightly higher numbers were
replaced in our analytics for that six
seven hour period on January 9th but I
could immediately tell that views were
dead there were videos that after 90
minutes after two hours have 2 000 or
fewer views again this is something that
just hasn't happened in years and you do
the math with 1.6 million subscribers it
just doesn't pass the sniff test